[Music]
hello everyone Perry here back in Park
City with another exclusive Collider
interview at the supper sweet big thanks
to our sponsors Kia for this for making
all this happen so we could talk about
movies that like Tesla I'm sitting here
with the team behind the movie hello and
congratulations thank you very much nice
to be here
so is this anybody's first Sundance I
have been here for a number of years is
there a certain time when it sort of
runs out statute runs out then you start
again I don't think the rules go there
okay okay no certainly not my first I
was wondering because we had a pretty
extensive conversation about like a
million movies that you had yeah no I
keep I gained 20 pounds and then I come
back every year so I'm kind of a
different person I'm fatter every time
yeah that's why we're here 20 years ago
exactly with a little movie called
Hamlet he was the bad guy and was bad
like Clark he was excellent and Ethan
was Hamlet so we brought the van back
together exactly what has it been like
returning thus far I know you guys
haven't had your premiere yet but you
know why was it important to you after
having that experience to debut this
movie at Sundance Sundance is the best
right we agree well the timing worked
out you feel I feel very lucky to be
here it's a great platform to launch a
film can you tell our audience a little
bit about the film I'm sure they can put
two and two together based on the title
but what is it about your story that
makes it different from any other
interpretation we've seen thus far
remarkably not obvious what the movie is
or how it does what it does
the Tesla story is channeled through an
morgue and the daughter of JP Morgan
played by Eve Hewson and so that puts a
unique spin on that ball and there
haven't really been tested in movies
Tesla's appeared as a guest figure in
other films but this is truly his story
but it's a group portrait Kyle plays
Edison Jim plays George Westinghouse
they were they were Titans but they were
also human beings and so we try to give
it an intimate quality even though it's
an epic
and I was reading that the script had
been optioned and what I think it was
the early 80s so can you tell us a
little bit about what the biggest
differences are between that initial
version and what we're gonna see on
screen Eve's character wasn't in that
version so I had to wait to make it
better to get Eve can you guys tell us a
little bit about your role in the movie
and why it was so instrumental to tell
the story give it a whirl okay well so
there's sort of two different worlds
that you see in the film there's one and
that is sort of in the contemporary
world who is telling you the story of
Tess's life and then you sort of step
into the story and I also play an in
that it was slightly different version
of the character but kind of the same
speaking from the future yeah so it's an
interesting take on but the crucial
factor that made the script better I
hope I think from the decades-old
version is that by being narrated by a
woman who wanted to be close to Tesla it
gave access to a side of him to his to
his inner life or as to his what he was
both resisting and clouding in his own
life because he's one thing one reason I
think there hasn't been a movie about
Tesla's he had no known romantic
relationships but the real I didn't want
to infringe on that reality but he had a
lot of women around him and Ann was a
significant one because her father
became a very powerful influence and
Tesla's life he was the most probably
the most influential money man in the
world at that time
so that fascinated me and it took me a
while to catch up with that situation
so I haven't seen the movie yet and in
the press notes it was described as you
being a little bit of a narrator is that
kind of voiceover narration zev
voiceover antah camera okay so it's a
mix of both right so it's a little
eccentric but we've seen what is it
the Jim John Hughes movie yes
many of them we've seen that you know
it's not extraordinary to have people
talk to the camera but Yves are good at
that so we have a bit of element that
was my one reservation that I said to
Michael and we
our meeting I was like I don't want to
do it I can't talk to camera but you
made me sit through was there a key to
any of the notes he gave you that made
you feel most comfortable with it I just
had to learn my lines Hurley I think
that was she achieved it beautifully
yeah yeah just learn your lines of the
jump between a modern implements that
appear in ya and then traipsing back
into the time the real time period so
there's different drunk history was a
big influence truly an intimidation
factor there and you use the word Titans
to describe your roles is that
nerve-racking jumping into portraying
such formidable forces like that it's
interesting you know because we similar
to this time period of this movie we
live in a time period of titans right
and you know I know that for George
Westinghouse the you know him versus
Morgan or even Edison it's there's a lot
of different shades of good or bad and
it'll be interesting I haven't seen the
film but to see what the take away you
know obviously every audience member
will have their own take away but to see
how this George Westinghouse is
interpreted did he take advantage of
Tesla was he doing the
best-case-scenario I'm dying to find out
do you sitting and watching the movie
through especially when you know your
your parts of a whole is there anything
that you didn't get to experience
working on this on set that you're
really excited scream I always enjoy
watching the other performers work
because my section was quite short with
four or five days I think or six days
maybe so I want to see what was going on
when I wasn't there and I'm at the point
my career now I don't really care
whatever but I'm very interested to
watch the other performers can you guys
tell me a little bit about working with
Ethan - I mean he he's the title
character here he's phenomenal you've
both worked with him before so is there
anything about his approach to the role
that surprised you we pretty much agree
to use an awful Ryan
I hate him he's the worst that's why
he's not here he's not here we could
talk about who's on the jury did you
know that yes voting generous we're not
in competition you gotta go up but he I
think if he were here he would tell us
what it's like working with him
he's I again I I was here 20 years ago
with Ethan and Kyle and he's been a
great friend and an enabler I could say
the movie wouldn't exist without him so
I can only heap praise on him and and
it's sincere because he's truly he's got
his own visionary passionate generous
generous spirit that I think is on
display in the movie in a very definite
way I think you know that generous of
spirit it's also so spontaneous so in
the movie you're never quite know and
he's up for anything he's just really
wonderful to work with are you the kind
of director who prefers that the cast
stick to the script or are you a little
more fluid on sex I know this is a
pretty significant project to pull off
in New York City on a limited budget
when I'm doing Shakespeare I like to
stick to the script but when it's my
script I think anything goes yeah so
what was it like on set collaborating
how much can you guys bring out in the
moment I mean I keep hearing you know
people find the film as the process
progresses did you find that happening
at all while you were shooting yeah I
think also because we were an Indian we
were shooting for like 30 days and we
didn't have that much money there were
some challenges you know I remember
coming to set some days and we had lost
our location and we all together sort of
had to come up with a solution so I
think in a way it was sort of like we
all pitched in and every day was an
emergency okay it was which I think made
the film better more interesting was so
fun about indie films is that everyone's
there for the right reason you know it's
not there's not some like if you're
looking for an ego trip you shouldn't be
doing an indie anyway yeah I mean and
it's but like they're also you know it's
obviously Michael's project and Ethan's
the lead but you know you can be a good
soldier and show up with ideas and
sometimes those ideas work and sometimes
so there's a collaborative spirit that I
think is so fun and I you know this is
my second film with Michael we did the
experimenter and you know it's this
ongoing movable process that is amazing
we gotta keep that trend going if you
got to do another movie with Michael now
cool and then you got to come back here
and we'll talk about all of them okay
great see you next year based on what
you just said this is a question I like
bringing up often but especially on an
independent film if you had a name and
unsung hero of this production someone
on the crew that we need to know more
about and the work that they brought to
the film who would you pick and why he's
not unsung but I just point to Michael
and probably because of what we were
speaking about before the collaborate
collaborative process that we have to go
through and Michael is nothing but that
I mean it's always about finding it and
is a discussion and conversations and
he's so smart that he you know he he'll
answer anything and it's and it's and he
just gives you all the energy and what
you need really as a character I assume
you I won't I'd like to pick someone
else to name but uh well the obvious
choice is the guy who who is both are
our favorite kind of grizzly bear Shawn
Williams the DP who is a very unique
character who manages to both be self
destructive and invaluable on almost
every day there's he's part of the
emergency and he's part of the rescue
operation and and it's funny to be to be
public about this but I'd I'd he'll ever
see this but um but he's incredibly
prolific he's almost willfully sticking
to independent films to low-budget films
European films but he's made over 50 or
maybe 70 movies and he's 41 I think so
he's I felt it's my second feature with
him my fourth film everything is not
easy but but the results are magnificent
so I would say let's vote for Shawn yeah
Shawn before I let you guys go we do
have a couple of rapid-fire supercut
questions actually before I even do that
Kyla I do want to bring up Twin Peaks
because we've all a ton of Twin Peaks
fans that watch our stuff and we worked
on a
Twin Peaks game so it's just a very
exciting thing to bring up a VR game and
just you know what was it like returning
returning to that world and how do you
feel about it now after the fact
David Lynch again was so special and to
revisit the character and characters
that I did none of them were the
highlights of my career thank you guys
so much for your time today
Tesla keep an eye out for it and other
big thanks to Kia for having us here in
the supper suite thanks for making these
interviews happen they can share this
one before you leave and stay tuned
because we got more coming your way from
Park City real soon